now we want to take this idea right we
want to actually
apply it so let's go back to um the
3d space that you've kind of drawn and
we're going to just draw
uh one octane of it for now i need to
catch up and actually draw one myself
because
we need to be able to say for example
understand some of our old concepts like
distance
in terms of this 3d world you know how
to work out distance
in a cartesian plane how do we do it say
if i had some point
a comma b comma c i've got three
coordinates not two because i'm in three
dimensions right
how to find the distance to a point like
that
now some of you already know the formula
good for you we need to know where it
comes from and why it actually works
which of these axes is which again which
one's this one x is coming out at you
right this one we have laid down on the
ground it's y
and that leaves z in the vertical okay
now
here's the tricky thing we're going from
2d to 3d right on your cartesian plane
if you put a spot like 5 on there
unambiguously
that's where it is but if on your page
you draw a point like say
this and say that
is a comma b comma c that gives you
almost no information about where it
actually is do you agree
this could be like in the front in the
octane we're looking at it could be in
the octane next door
or the octane underneath and i'm just
looking through it to see
into what's going on so here's the way
i'm going to ask us to represent this
let's see if i can do this well i'm
actually going to rub that off because
i'm not going to end there
our a b and c they're just going to be
constants in the x
and y and z directions okay so let's
deal with one at a time
if i want to move a units in the x
direction and again like i said if your
other colors this will really help you
start from the origin and draw with me
a nice obvious vector
right that goes in the x direction just
for simplicity because i only drew the
one octant here
let's just assume a b and c are positive
okay you can generalize this it doesn't
matter whether they're positive or not
if this is going in the a direction
sorry in the x direction
but its magnitude is a then i can call
this thing i can say well
that's its length a in the x direction
okay now the next thing i have to do is
i have to go in the
y direction which way is that again i'm
assuming that everything's positive just
to make things simple which way am i
going to draw my next vector
right i'm going to go to the right right
because that's positive y if i drew the
negative
y axis would be going this way so i'm
going to draw and be careful with this
you'll definitely need a ruler
i'm going to need to go parallel to the
y-axis
in the y-direction are you with me and
i'm going to go let's see if i can do
this
reasonably clearly i'm going to go how
far
i'm going to go b that's that's how many
you know units i want to go
or you know there might be other units
there okay
so there's been you can imagine where
i'm going to go finally i'm now trying
to go
c units in the z direction and you all
establish for me
that's going up isn't it so just be
careful
what is up on your 3d space
right you want to be parallel to that
because that's what it means to go in
the z direction so i'm just going to
come away for a second all right let's
put it
there
and that's going to be c in length so
you can see now i have a way of actually
visualizing what's going on and how i
get to
a b c it's by actually connecting
three different vectors in three
different directions
so now i can label this point a b
c so how do i find the distance say for
example from the origin
to this point how do we find distance on
a regular
cartesian plane what knowledge do we use
back from year 8.
we use pythagoras right and we're going
to use pythagoras again
i'm going to use an old trick from your
extension one course which is to take 3d
stuff
which hurts my brain on a flat surface
and turn it into
2d there are a bunch of right angled
triangles hiding in this diagram and i
just need to articulate them
clearly i'm going to start where i'm
normally familiar which is this bottom
you know flat floor here the x the x y
plane
okay can we draw the right angle
triangle that's going to fit along
here and now owing to the fact that this
is in three dimensions and i'm trying to
represent
perspective that looks nothing lighter
like a right angle right but can you
tell me
where is the right angle hiding in this
particular
polygon where would you describe it as
between
shall you
do you hear that the right angle is
formed by my a vector
and my b vector now that is absolutely
correct but how can i
know that she's right something you give
me a good answer i want to see if
someone else
can work it out veren you are very
patient what's your reasoning
[Music]
um
yeah fantastic this is the whole point
of defining x y and z axes
they are each orthogonal to each other
so therefore
vectors that are parallel so those guys
will also be
orthogonal with me can you please draw
this particular triangle here but now
let's orient it in a way that we can
actually see the right angle triangle
going on i think i can sneak it in up
here
and as you can see i'm going to do my
very best to try and match colors so you
can see
what is going on here
so now i'm looking at the xy plane face
on
right directly on and because this is
just a
right angle triangle on a plane you guys
can tell me what the hypotenuse is
go ahead i'll give you a clue it starts
with the square root right yes square
root of
a squared plus b squared thank you we'll
just go straight to there we're in
extension two we don't need to proof
pythagoras theorem all over again that's
okay
if it makes you feel better right by
inspection i'm now going to go from here
into three dimensions i was just dealing
with x y
right now where is this other right
angle triangle that i was mentioning
where is it hiding what direction how
would you describe it
between the vector a plus b and vector c
between the vector a plus b which is my
dotted one here
nice i i should probably put you know to
actually represent i was just
representing lengths here but you get
the idea so that guy there is a plus b
and then if you join it to c that's
going to be on a new plane if you wanted
by the way
that's also going to go through the
z-axis do you agree i'm going right in
through the origin okay
let's draw that this guy here looks even
less like a right angled triangle
than this one does but it is it's just a
trick of perspective
again the question this one's a little
trickier where's the right angle in this
triangle
where is it what do you think almond
yeah
like from the origin to like the quarter
like that one
yeah that one that one and then those
guys
that's exactly now by the way just can i
point out right calvin is wrestling with
the same thing we're all
like this is just a limitation of this
medium we're using and your brains are
going to struggle with it too
that's why notation is so very important
in this okay let me maybe draw this
triangle
face on just like we did before and
maybe it'll be a little bit clearer
uh what have i got i've got c
i'm going to draw that facing up i don't
know why i drew that so comically large
i've got as xiao called it a
plus b which is this dotted one and it's
on my
where am i
that's on my xy plane on the floor as it
were
i should put that i've already got an
arrow there good okay
so this orange line do you see where
it's going now this is from
what is this what's the name of that
point that i'm starting out down the
bottom
that's the origin right and then it goes
up to our chosen point that was a
terrible marker to choose
our chosen point a comma b comma c
right so now is it a little bit clearer
which one is the right angle
it's going to be between
this is i'm going to call it a plus b
and this one i'm going to call
c you see where the right angle is why
is the right angle between those
particular
vectors these ones here
think about the logic you used before
right
very nice this plane here the x y plane
which a plus b sits on do you agree it's
orthogonal to the
z-axis and anything parallel to the
z-axis which c
is okay so we've got a right angle there
uh we already have this length right
this length here is equal to the square
root of a squared
plus b squared we already got c up here
so what does that tell you from
pythagoras
again a second time what does that tell
you about our actual final thing our
distance here
again it's a square root right what's
underneath a squared
plus b squared plus e squared hooray
pythagoras turns up everywhere
even nicely generalizing into three
dimensions are you happy with that okay
now why do we do this
two reasons i take that back three
reasons number one to just get you
familiar again
with the 3d world but handling it in a
coordinate system which we've never done
before that was reason number one
reason number two we're going to be
working out a whole lot of
vectors and magnitudes of vectors how do
you work out the magnitude
of a vector it's just with its length
right it's distance between two things
okay and then lastly and this will be
the last kind of
cool neat thing that we're going to get
out of here and then i'm going to set
you to work
we can get a whole kind of shape out of
this
particular formula here this distance
formula right
if we call this p right
the distance of the origin to p is going
to be equal to
this square root a squared plus b
squared plus
c squared now remind me so take a second
so think about it carefully
what kind of shape do you get what kind
of shape do you get
if you have some particular point
and then you say you know what any point
that is the same distance from that spot
there
i'll include in two dimensions we would
call this a
circle right but as we generalize into
three dimensions we would call that a
sphere right so a sphere is that set of
points
that all have a central
defined distance which we would call
that
the radius and then
we say well i just measure from a
particular point
up to well let's see here this is going
to be a bit long so you might want to
draw this long square root sign with me
right my
x wants to be some distance from a
because that's in the x direction
my b once sorry my y needs to be some
distance from b because that's in the y
direction
and then lastly my z wants to be
somewhere measured from c
because that's in the z direction
now of course if you wanted and had
something against radical science
because you're like who wants to write
such a long thing right
you just square both sides r squared
equals
x minus a l squared plus y minus bl
squared
plus z minus cl squared and that's the
equation
of a sphere make sense
so three reasons hopefully familiarity
with this 3d world we will get to
magnitudes of vectors that'll be next
lesson just to remind you of how that
works but in three dimensions
and you're going to encounter some
spheres in this exercise and being able
to recognize what they are
is pretty important to start with
distance okay